it has been a struggle for so many of
you and your interactions with dieter
over the last months but it's also
caused some of you
to go really above and beyond for your
neighbors
earlier today we told you and joe
moeller's story about an issue a deter
causing
payment delays we were told exactly or
never told exactly what the issue was
dieter did tell us
they're working on it and payments uh
could show up in a couple of days
but one man like many others doesn't
have much time to wait
he told us his power will soon be shut
off among other things
continues to compound that stress of
trying to find a job trying to deal with
dieter
worrying about christmas i mean i have
five kids here in the household
and i've had to go out for help for
christmas as well
because you know it's just it's been so
rough this year
five kids but remember we mentioned
about helping neighbors
when joe did this story earlier on today
in our early evening eight news now
newscast right after it aired
a viewer stepped up to pay the 239
dollar
power bill for elijah and elijah's
family
now the lights will be on right through
the holiday season right through
christmas
elijah said the stranger's generosity
actually moved him to tears